[Music]
is the hijab 10
discount code for 10 percent discount on
a wide range of products including
premium ethiopian black seed products
assalamu alaikum
how are you guys doing i'm joined it's
the champ champ connection here how are
you doing
[Laughter]
so much one letter can make such a big
difference
well one mistake can make such a big
difference and today we're going to be
talking about the the big mistake from
cosmic coward cosmic failure cosmic
coward call him whatever you want to
call him actually to be honest with you
just some time ago maybe it was before
maybe two three weeks ago i made a video
about him actually praising some of what
he was doing because
he was talking about how
voracious he didn't mention this kind of
language but he the contingency argument
was
and how he he sees it as
the absurdity of the infinite regression
whatever now
for some strange reason in fact that we
can both comment on he's decided to
attack the muslim community again yes
and before we talk about him attacking
the muslim community let's really
distinguish because the video that he
took down okay which he initially had up
was why is islam so sensitive or
something to that effect right yes
islam here he's not talking about if you
like the religion he's talking he is
talking about muslim people because he
actually mentions
muslims and their reactions to uh
certain things that provocations or
whatever it is
this ungrammatical use of the word islam
to refer to muslim people this
ungrammatical use
is a commonplace usage
among people on the alt-right people on
the even the far right
that try
maybe disguise their islamophobia
disguise their
the the hasty generalizations against
know it's like tommy robinson you know i
don't have a problem with the muslims
this is islam right right but to be
completely honest with you you mentioned
tommy robinson right
he wasn't as cowardly as this i mean he
wouldn't he wouldn't pop a video and
then put it down and say because of
safety concern you couldn't imagine that
that was nonsense yeah imagine imagine
totally put on a video yeah and putting
it taking it down at least he had a
degree of being rough and ready like you
know he had a certain level of
courageousness and you can say in the
twitter level he did a certain level of
courageousness that this little boy
doesn't unfortunately does not have they
do also have something in common you
know tommy robinson and katie hopkins
and all these people they have something
in common they use the fear factor yeah
and that's exactly what he's done it's
very strange because it's a fallacy of a
circular argument and it's a
self-fulfilled prophecy i'm not saying
he claimed these or
what i'm trying to say is he puts a
video up and he says why islam so
sensitive and you know muslims do all
kinds of burn places bomb places etc and
then it takes this video down so it's
like it's like it's pretty nice
i'm proving my own point but i made the
video it got about 300 000 views i'll
take it down now because i'm under fret
i mean was he under threat when he made
certain statements which you're going to
mention you know well actually you know
this is a good point because if he was
so scared about his safety why doesn't
he take his other video down which is
which he's actually insulting the
prophet muhammad
so he mounted quote and abused yes
he still got that one up so that one's
more dangerous if you're talking about
threat levels yeah i would have thought
that one would be the one to take down
or even worse according muslim woman in
bags yeah i mean i'm somalian women
somali women in bags is especially you
know me i'll be honest with you you've
got to be careful of the somalian
sisters you know what i'm saying
i'm telling you you know especially if
you're saying they're in bed some other
sisters can you know give you a little
you know the point here is this you was
brave then yeah what have you become a
coward now is it what the meat that
you're not eating you're vegan now is it
has an effect on your testosterone
is it that is it the the b12 and the
iron deficiency that oxygen doesn't
happen
what is
let's say something right yeah some
muslims will come and say why are you
treating this guy like this and it's the
same muslims that they don't mind being
slapped up quite frankly
and to be honest that's you guys yeah
yeah yeah this man
is language yeah look this man clearly
doesn't mind throwing you and your
family and your community under the bus
okay he's done that already how many
videos does he have to make not just
about islam yeah and about the prophet
muhammad but about you and your
community and how you act he's hastily
generalizing 1.8 billion people exactly
you know speaking about islam
really intending muslims and he
mentioned the word muslims few times in
the video now of course and the funny
thing is is his comeback he makes it
very clear which is very bizarre i'm he
goes cosmic is back why are you not back
with the video attacking christianity
have you got is that on twitter he said
he deleted it oh he deleted it on
twitter
what i remember what he showed me was
that he was saying something effect of
um
the old cosmic and here's one for you
guys no no that's what i'm trying to do
it's like the fans were saying can we
get exactly what you said he i i've got
it here
yeah because from what i know he was
basically saying like you guys were
asking here's the old cosmic background
because people fed up with his vegan
videos
so the thing is if you can find that
i got it here i got it i got it i got it
right he goes people keep telling me
that they miss the old skeptic yeah
well here you go here you go i guess so
it's like he's a slave to his uh exactly
no need to not only that it just shows
how islamophobic you are because you
coming back mean it didn't mean that hey
cosmic's back with um you know an
intellectual
and scrutinizing whatever it may be
different topics he discusses with he
goes straight for islam absolutely and
why why islam
and he got a big backlash from his
followers
even saw them
which i'll tell you is actually
something in the quran this video fails
to consider the fundamental point yeah
what if islam was actually right if if
if muhammad was actually allah's prophet
they would be justified in in
disregarding other viewpoints
yeah so the point is that is a good
point because the thing is this is not
actually a logical argument against
islam he's just trying to create a shock
factor yes against islam but then if we
want to create shock factors he's he's
had peter singer who's one of the
leading utilitarians
um
he actually he's one of the top
scholars of utilitarianism and and he
mentions
you know let me actually get exactly
what he mentions he compares basically
black people african people slaves
in the slave trade to animal suffering
and he's got this in his channel right
he doesn't even challenge it enough
because remember they don't take the
premise of human exceptionalism for
granted the idea that human is special
is differentiate from the animal uh the
human being is the friendship from an
animal that's obviously we believe in
that
we believe in the quran
you know the quran states that we have
exalted
the child of adam we have exalted human
being yeah
you know
this is human exceptionalism in the
quran we have an uh you know a moral
human exceptionism they don't have it so
they can compare black people no problem
with animals
they have track record of doing this
kind of thing um talking about somali
and women african people you know and
these kind of things and that shows the
extent to which that they have this kind
of western gaze orientalizing
orientalizing you know uh looking at
these other look why don't you compare
white people with uh with animals why
did i have to be the african example
you know that's right you know and
there's there's another thing as well
which i wish i want to add on on this
point which is that um
peter singer since we're talking about
him right listen to what he says this is
something that um he writes in his book
it's called practical ethics yeah
he says he he says this man that he had
on his podcast and he didn't even
challenge him all these points by the
way it's one of the most can we talk
about shock factor he's creating this
this this monster of the muslim world
and the monster of islam
the the the very um
school of thought if you like ethical
school of thought which he sympathizes
with
and has people coming on who are
scholars off right in fact leading
scholars off
this is what ps uh singer says listen he
says the child's life
prospects significantly less promising
than those of a normal child
and then he says he has argued that
parents are those children this is not
his words but this is what the person is
writing in the in the article
of those with those conditions should be
allowed to end the child's life and it's
in the guardian this is not an argument
against utilitarianism as being right or
wrong
likewise mentioning the classical laws
of apostasy is not an argument of islam
being right and wrong yeah
even if look if we accept his premise
muslims and islam are sensitive yeah
does that make them wrong exactly it
doesn't you see now you have to with
your subjective morality
you have to now prove that being
sensitive
is he not hardcore
right good point before this that's the
case
but this point here was yeah
that's a very good point but the if he
hasn't gone objective standard yeah on
what basis is
can he prove yeah that
being almost being sensitive in his
words is a bad thing and if it's not
about things that's a superfluous it's
superfluous
absolutely not so the second thing you
should mention is very good point which
is that he is determined he's a hard
determinist
hard determinist really don't have a
case to make about morality at all
because hard determinists are saying
basically let's explain this they're
they are saying that there's an
antecedent causal chain
of uh uh you know of causes before
that basically render what's happening
with the human being as some kind of
ventriloquism right we are forced to do
what we are doing even the thoughts that
i have i am forced to have them i don't
have any free will at all
this is the argument that sam harris
made and daniel dennett who's a
compatibilist he refutes him on this
actually right the point i'm making is
if you are a determinist you have no
claim to morality at all and not only
that you can't put blame on anyone yes
like you've mentioned right you just
said this
because if you put blame on what basis
they are being forced by antecedent
causal uh things so
the the video is sloppy i think he knows
because i mean he says he's especially
he told sabor ahmed you know he told me
he wants to specialize in islam and in
the video that you refuted in a very
good way by the way and i i suggest
everyone goes on your channel and watch
the video because it's more detailed
than this one
because he tried putting the video down
i suggest people go on his channel and
see what kind of ridiculous comments he
made and ali that was refuting him so
rahman
he is a
islamic specialist he wants to
specialize in islam and the university
of oxford right
but then but then as you mentioned in
your video near the end of the video
he says in the quran there's some kind
of punishment for apostles in the quran
right yeah there is nothing
this shows you haven't even read the
quran yeah how can you specialize yeah
you haven't even read it in english
exactly yeah forget about memorizing it
yeah forget about memorizing it we're
we're told off we're not memorizing it
properly not only that and he believes
he believes which had refuted that
non-muslims have to have unconditional
love to the prophet and we know one
example of the treaty of
that when um
the treaty done with right right
um
uh
he came and he said we don't see you as
a prophet of god and he said to ali the
process take my name off ali didn't even
even want to take you off i think he
knows this
come on
no no i think no i'm not giving him an
excuse you are i'm saying that someone
who goes to university of oxford he
doesn't know someone who no but you know
maybe it's true maybe but i'm sure he
has not been taught to this effect this
is this is not just a shame to him it's
a shame to the institution it's a shame
to the university that that he studied
in you cannot shame your university like
this by by speaking about islam in such
a way that you don't even know you're
mentioning things that are in the holy
book well maybe that's why
i'm not even in the holy well maybe
maybe that was i think he's a very
clever man he took the video down and
blamed on security reasons because if
you think about it there's too many
fallacies everyone does it yeah if you
have two options you're going to be
intellectually dishonest and embarrass
yourself and we know he doesn't like
scrutiny yeah because of course
yeah or you're going to say you know
what actually
what does everyone like what's
i had to take it down oh my gosh
cosmic's video was good but he took it
down with difference that's what the
hell he flipped and he's a coward
because and this is the last thing why
is if he lost his food too much freedom
speech so much why is he coming
practically desperately in a desperate
scurry trying to get me to take a video
down yeah a small video of him in sabor
ahmad yeah where ah schools him
basically right uh atheists rattled why
blaming him
he was threatening me illegally i said
okay look what is it
we went through a privacy thing we went
through a whole process
he lost sorry that youtube against him
my video is still up it's on a hundred
thousand views almost yeah yeah yeah
that's why he wants to give that to a
million that's it that's good yeah yeah
so so if he wants freedom of speech so
much why is he so desperate to have
things in his control
like he was trying to get the debate in
his control for so long or get things
taken down which are not in his favor
he's thin skinned and you know what i
think he's doing he's basically pro he's
projecting and he has to ask himself
maybe he can think about himself is he
projecting put this in a question format
are you projecting your own securities
onto the muslim community are you
projecting
are you um scapegoating the muslim
community are you trying to create what
what um edward said called didactic
representation you know where you have a
good guy and a bad guy and this is the
trope of the orientalist and this is the
narrative of the right wing he's
unfortunately he's put he's put forward
the the narrative the hasty
generalization the right wing yeah
unfortunately he's not being able to
substantiate it and uh your refutation
refer people to your reputation uh for
more information at the end guys yeah
and i think that's it man you can very
clearly see and people are bored of this
and we can see right through you um and
that's it guys hope you enjoyed the
video one last thing i want to say to
people this is what is the last thing
i'll say
please guys yeah there's something in
the religion and even if you don't want
to label it formally it's called
it's where you disassociate not just
with people not just with ideas but with
people as well someone who's so
so forthright in their to be honest with
the arrogance against not just islam but
the muslim community themselves
we have been nice to this guy whenever i
put a video you know and i mentioned
something good about him the muslim
people in the comment section are very
very
i would say accommodating to him making
dua for him supplicating for him hoping
that you know he understands that his
ignorance is alleviated and so on
but now enough is enough
this guy clearly is trying to use our
good name and our kindness he's taking
kindness for weakness and you know the
thing that stops people like this
because i think i know what's going on
here i just want to end with this really
just because someone has a um a cowardly
temperament a cowardly he's got a
cowardly temperament right
he's a passive cowardly temperament he's
he's a bit me
that is a meek and cowardly temperament
it's a predisposition it's a
psychological predisposition do not
confuse a passive
and a cowardly temperament with humility
and with sincerity
he might have things in him which are
sincere and which are
fine but he's not i'm sorry he's not a
sincere person because he wasn't he
would not be using
the good name of islam and the good name
of the muslim community in this country
to throw us under the bus so he can get
fans to like his videos and so he can uh
so he can raise his ranks well this is
where charities and allah says in the
quran the disbelievers people like him
who have animosity will never be pleased
with you until you follow their way so
that's exactly what's going on here brom
sisters um and yeah that's it
salaam alaikum
you